- [Instructor] When dissolved in water,
a strong base like potassium hydroxide
will dissociate completely in solution
to form hydroxide ions.
Potassium hydroxide is an example
of a group 1A metal hydroxide.
Other examples include lithium hydroxide
and sodium hydroxide.
Group 2A metal hydroxides
are also considered
to be strong bases.
For example, calcium hydroxide
is a group 2A metal hydroxide,
and so is strontium hydroxide.
Let's do a problem with a
group 1A metal hydroxide,
sodium hydroxide.
Let's say the pH of the solution is 13.00
and our goal is to calculate
the initial concentration
of sodium hydroxide.
First, we brought out
the disillusion equation.
Solid sodium hydroxide
dissociates completely in water
to form sodium cations and
hydroxide anions in solution.
Looking at the balanced equation,
there's a one in front of sodium hydroxide
and a one in front of hydroxide ions,
therefore the concentration
of hydroxide ions
is equal to the initial
concentration of sodium hydroxide.
And we can find the
concentration of hydroxide ions
in solution from the pH.
At 25 degrees Celsius,
the pH plus the pOH is equal to 14.00.
So we can plug the pH into our equation,
which gives us 13.00,
plus the pOH is equal to 14.00.
So the pOH of the
solution is equal to 1.00,
and the pOH is equal to the negative log
of the concentration of hydroxide ions.
So we can plug the pOH into this equation,
which gives us 1.00 is
equal to the negative log
of the concentration of hydroxide ions.
To solve for the concentration
of hydroxide ions in solution,
first we move the negative
sign to the left side,
which gives us negative
1.00 is equal to the log
of the concentration of hydroxide ions.
To get rid of the log,
we take 10 to both sides.
So the concentration of
hydroxide ions in this solution
is equal to 10 to the negative 1.00,
which is equal to .10 molar.
Because sodium hydroxide is a strong base
that dissociates completely in solution
to form hydroxide ions,
if the concentration of hydroxide ions
in solution is .10 molar,
so is the initial concentration
of sodium hydroxide.
Now let's do a problem with
a group 2A metal hydroxide.
Let's say the initial
concentration of a solution
of calcium hydroxide is .0010 molar,
and our goal is to find
the pH of the solution
at 25 degrees Celsius.
Calcium hydroxide is a strong base
that dissociates completely in solution
to form calcium two plus
ions and hydroxide anions,
and looking at the mole ratios
in this disillusion equation,
there's a one in front
of calcium hydroxide,
a one in front of calcium two plus,
and a two in front of hydroxide ions.
Since the mole ratio of
calcium hydroxide to calcium
is one to one,
if the initial concentration
of calcium hydroxide
is .0010 molar,
that's also the concentration
of calcium ions.
So it's .0010 molar in solution.
The mole ratio of calcium
hydroxide to hydroxide ions
is one to two,
so if the initial concentration
of calcium hydroxide
is .0010 molar,
the concentration of
hydroxide ions in solution
is twice that concentration,
so two times .0010 molar
is equal to .0020 molar.
Now that we know the
concentration of hydroxide ions,
we can calculate the pH of the solution.
One way to calculate the
pH is to first find the pOH
of the solution,
and pOH is equal to the negative log
of the concentration of hydroxide ions.
So we can plug in the
concentration of hydroxide ions
into our equation,
which gives us the pOH of the solution
is equal to the negative log of .0020,
and when you do the calculation,
the pOH is equal to 2.70.
Notice, since we have
two significant figures
for the concentration,
we need two decimal places for our pOH.
So to find the pH,
we know that pH plus pOH is equal to 14.00
at 25 degrees Celsius.
So we can plug in the pOH of 2.70,
and that gives us pH plus
2.70 is equal to 14.00.
So the pH of the solution
is equal to 11.30.